[Musique]
un semblant de retour à la normale dans
les rues de kaboul si le choc des
événements des derniers jours reste bien
présent dans les esprits et les
habitants de la capitale afghane sortent
à nouveau comme ici pour se rendre au
marché
l'objectif des taliban est à présent de
rassurer la population
c'est la raison pour laquelle en
conférence de presse leur stratégie de
communication saxe en partie sur la
place des femmes dans la société si dieu
le veut conforme à la charia nous
réaliserons les choses à travailler
important de la société et nous les
respectons dans tous les domaines de la
vie là où la société en a besoin elles
auront une présence active
les insurgés ont également annoncé une
amnistie générale pour leurs opposants
avant leur prise de pouvoir y compris
les responsables politiques sans
toutefois donner plus de détails selon
berlin les talibans empêchent les
personnes qui veulent quitter le
territoire d'accéder à l'aéroport de
kaboul la veille ces images avait sidéré
le reste du monde à dézinguant prêt à
tout pour fuir leur pays tentait de
s'accrocher à cet avion américain
décollant de la capitale beaucoup sont
restés au sol certains ont réussi à
pénétrer à l'intérieur de l'appareil le
secrétaire général de l'otan jens
stoltenberg s'est exprimé sur la
situation
livrant son analyse sur l'impuissance du
gouvernement afghan face aux talibans
silence fut weeks mais l'état ce que
nous avons vu ces dernières semaines
c'est un effondrement militaire et
politique à une vitesse qui n'avait pas
été prévu une partie des forces de
sécurité afghanes ont combattu avec
courage
quand mais elles n'ont pas été en mesure
de sécuriser le pays parce qu'en fin de
compte le leadership politique afghan
n'a pas réussi à tenir tête aux talibans
et obtenir la solution pacifique que les
afghans souhaitait désespérément cet
échec des autorités afghanes est à
l'origine de la tragédie à laquelle nous
assistons aujourd'hui ceux de 3g
witnessing de nombreux pays exfiltre
leurs ressortissants à l'instar de la
france qui mènent des opérations pour
rapatrier les quelques dizaines de
citoyens français encore présents sur
place